that's good interesting all right so
what do I talk to you about today is 50
shades of lipstick and this is a talk
which is very kind of very broad
reaching we're gonna look at a bunch of
different security things it is meant to
show you how wide this industry is how
many crazy stuff or how much crazy stuff
actually goes on and I thought we might
start with this is just talking a little
bit about how accessible hacking is
today and I guess we've got a lot of
devs out there probably not a lot of
people who could go home and put on
their hoodies and hack stuff so
hopefully this will give you a bit of an
idea of how easy it is to break into
stuff and I wanted to start with this
kid and this kid was in the news a
couple of years ago and he hacked the
Xbox and he did genuinely hack it as
well five year old kid because what he's
done is he's managed to circumvent the
parental controls on the Xbox so he can
play call of duty or whatever it is that
five-year-olds want to play that they're
not allowed to he's on the Microsoft
security researchers Hall of Fame he did
actually get a bug bounty parottas all
how proud would he be as a dad you know
and look how excited is he's totally
stoked so he got paid money he's found
this risk and he's five years old and it
was actually a vulnerability so when I
talk about democratizing hacking it's
making it so accessible to everyone and
what a lot of people don't realize is
just how easy it is to hack into stuff
and just how accessible tools are to
help you do it so tools like this this
is a Chrome extension it's called Bishop
you install the extension and then you
just browse around the web doing what
you would normally do when you're
browsing and in the background it goes
around and it looks for things like
exposed version control systems
misconfigured admin tools so it's making
these requests to things like dot get in
the sort in the roots of the repository
so is there a dot git repository in
there summit and it finds it and it
collects at all and then you come back
and you review it and then once you find
the source control repository well use
your imagination it all sort of goes
downhill from there
and the crazy thing about this is that
this really is just something that runs
in the background so you need not know
anything about security and you can run
these tools if you do actually want to
learn how to break into websites you can
find a lot of tutorials so things like
this this is a tutorial that shows how
to find a URL that has an ID in it you
put a single quote in that ID so it's no
longer an integer you load the page and
now you've got an exception that shows a
sequel error and what you do then is you
going you copy the URL and you go to
this free software called javed you
paste it in there and then you get all
the data and that is literally it that
is the entire thing end to end I'm going
to demo this firsthand tomorrow morning
and you'll see just how easy it is to
actually get all the data at a system it
is literally copy and paste so if you
actually want to learn how to break into
systems you can find a lot of
information like that if you want to
delegate the breaking in of systems to
someone else you gon hire a hacker and
there are websites like this which are
designed just purely to hire hackers
these are the hackers you can see that
there they're a nice sort of gender race
age diverse group which i think is very
important in hacking they all look very
friendly you can start a project for
free as well you know this is how
accessible it's becoming to actually get
people to break into systems if you
don't want to learn how to do it
yourself now the problem we've got is
that because it is so easy to break into
these systems we've got issues like this
activist who actually knows what a
hacktivist is because it's like we've
got a bit of an opinion right like
there's some kind of shady character and
maybe it's anonymous maybe something
like that I really like this definition
of a activist firstly if you're not
already following Swift on security
guard follow her or him or whoever it is
behind this persona because they're
they're hilarious and they're actually
really insightful as well and this
very true right what we see is them
breaking into systems and making up
reasons why they deserved it give a good
example one from down here a couple
years ago anonymous we know they're
anonymous because they told us anonymous
break into an Australian government
website defaced it and it was AA per
stray or up trapwire
up you know whatever like they'll make
something up and they were obviously
very proud of themselves breaking in
this Australian government website
except it wasn't there's an NGO so they
break into a non-government organisation
which was a website to help people with
disabilities recover rehabilitate but
they thought it was a gov website so
they're like okay we'll just break into
this stuff and the reason why is
whatever the hell is said on the
previous page doesn't really matter we
saw something really similar earlier
this year EXO you know see anonymous
ddosed Neeson right like the carmaker
why do you reckon you ddosed Nissen is
that you know like you don't like their
cars or give you a hint
so Nissen is from japan why would a
nonnamous not like a japanese company
it's the whales right okay so how
anonymous is ddos to listen because
japan is doing scientific research with
the whales and that's what happened this
is the point right they make up a reason
and sort of the serious note here is for
all of you responsible for websites you
don't need to have something that's of
obvious value the fact that you are on
the Internet is enough reason there'll
be some other reason why they broke into
it later on the worry better then now
that means is we get guys like this so
Jake Davies and Ryan Cleary they're both
here turning up to court after being
busted as members of LulzSec lost
circles very active a few years ago
break into a lot of stuff actually very
very effective and again just teenagers
kids - most of us in the colloquial
sense of it younger than us it's only up
to court here with them mums look at
expression on their mum's faces - yeah
they are well and truly grounded after
is the kids right and incidentally kids
like this are really really good at
things like social engineering if any of
you have kids think about how effective
your kids are at pushing your buttons on
various things
malicious kids are very good at doing
that to organizations and getting
information from them that they then use
to break into other systems so they're
they're quite adept at that on a bit of
a more serious note the the problem that
this creates is that you end up with
kids like this that are curious that are
not yet really aware of the consequences
of their actions and they end up
becoming criminals because this is what
happens they're broken into systems
they've stolen data out of there they're
gonna get their asses kicked one way or
the other and for many of us who may
have been kids before we had internet or
smartphones or things like that like we
could get away with this stuff that was
localized it wasn't a major thing but
you play up now and you play up online
and the next thing you know is you're a
criminal now we see a lot of interesting
criminal activity online when it comes
to hacking
so we'll see things like this this is
from paste bin and this is when Dropbox
was hacked except they weren't really
hacked because people make this stuff up
they go hey Dropbox got hacked here's
nearly seven million accounts on paste
bin if you give us some Bitcoin we'll
put more stuff up there it's not real
but they're hoping people will give
Bitcoin and when you can anonymize your
identity and then you can go on to an
anonymous service like paste bin dump
stuff up there and then ask for Bitcoin
pretty low overhead isn't it you know
the arrow oh and that's going to be
pretty good they don't have to get much
Bitcoin for that to have made a lot of
sense more seriously though one of the
things that we've seen particularly over
the last few months is stuff like this
this is from yesterday
this is allegedly 200 million yahoo
accounts 200 million now only about six
or eight weeks ago we saw on this same
dark market website
we saw LinkedIn 180 million accounts we
saw MySpace 360 million accounts and
they were legitimate they were
that were hacked out of both those
organizations they both acknowledged it
and said yes this was us it happened
several years ago and it just resurfaced
but it appears on these dark market
websites and what's kind of fascinating
about this is first of all if you have
never visited a dark market website and
it sounds like this hard to obtain place
and it sounds like the online equivalent
like going down to the docks at night
and there shady people and you know it's
dangerous it's not you open up the tor
browser bundle which you can download
for free or you get any tor address and
you put teo at the end of it to use the
tor to web service and you're on the
duck market and when you're in there it
will look familiar it will look like
eBay we've got this guy here you can see
under Yahoo 200 million it says buy
peace of mind peace of mind is a good
guy he's got a hundred percent positive
feedback right
he sold a bunch of different other data
breaches he sold LinkedIn and he sold
myspace and his product was good good in
the sense that it was what was
represented reputation is really really
important in these sites so when you see
this and you see Yahoo being sold by
song with a hundred percent positive
reputation and a track history of
delivering you go this is probably in a
be legit so what's this so next few days
we might actually see Yahoo acknowledge
it at the moment they're like we can
neither confirm nor deny they can't take
that line for too long now in case
you're wondering for dark market
websites like is it is it really dark or
is it just a little bit shady whilst
you're on this site buying Yahoo data
you can also buy cocaine because all
this stuff is on the same site data
breaches cocaine drugs exploits it's all
on the same site this guy's a good guy
he's got a hundred percent as well it
must be good five grams of cocaine no
rory's and it all sits there on this one
site and this is what's sort of
happening now where we've got this class
of commodity if you like which is the
data breach which is sitting alongside
cocaine so interesting times all very
very accessible data other criminal
activities we see often perpetuated
online sometimes perpetuated
real life and stuff like this there's a
couple of years ago and these guys were
sending around these extortion notices
now this was actually in the mail gets
folded up putting an envelope sent out
this went to a pizza shop in New York
and said we haven't done anything to you
yet but unless we can you give us
Bitcoin and it's always about Bitcoin
right because it's much harder to trace
unless you give us Bitcoin we're gonna
say that you're growing marijuana you
know or that you got rats in your
kitchen or something like that and
they're just threats just extortion it's
like standover tactics but it's all done
remotely and you pay your Bitcoin online
via anonymous Asian services so the web
actually makes it really easy to stand
up these sorts of malicious kind of
intent sites in fact this is one of the
problems with tor tor is very good if
you're a political dissident and you're
trying to talk to people or if your
freedom of speech is being suppressed
because you live in Beijing or Turkey or
something like that tours great for that
but it's also great for doing really
really nasty stuff in fact recently
CloudFlare said that 94% of the traffic
the base or come from tour was malicious
and then tor said not like that's not
right
you know it's nearly not that bad but
there is a huge amount of traffic on tor
which is bad news other criminal sorts
of activities who see stuff like this
because you might have been wondering
what do hackers do with the money once
they get them well yeah now we know
where they spend it now the reason why
this works so well for hackers is that
they're compromising routers and what
they're doing is they're using attacks
such as cross-site request forgery where
you go to a page and your browser is
tricked into making a request to
somewhere else they use CSRF risks in
modems to update DNS settings so you're
just browsing around the web and you go
to might just be a new site and there's
an infected ad there because you can buy
ad space you can run your own scripts
and ads and it causes your browser to
make a post to change your DNS to their
malicious server and then when you type
in my bank comm you actually go to their
bank comm because you can reroute the
traffic with DNS
so we see that sort of criminal activity
happening quite a bit and on the one
hand you might look at this and go well
this is really depressing right there's
all these criminals breaking into all
our things the good news is is that they
also they also kind of screw up quite a
lot they do some really really stupid
things and I thought it might make us
all feel a little bit better if we
looked at some of the stupid things that
criminals do I'll give you an example
here's a good one
it's from Stack Overflow now this looks
like quite a reasonable question all
right someone wanting to connect to a
tor hidden service using curl the person
who posted this was a guy named Ross
orbit Ross Ulbricht was also known as
the Dread Pirate Roberts also known as
the mastermind behind the Silk Road dark
market which was notorious for selling
drugs he was also trying to have about
six people killed which didn't work in
his favor once he did get picked up but
the amusing thing about it is one of the
things that actually eventually led the
authorities to Ross was he posted this
Stack Overflow comment with an account
that had an email address it was
traceable back to him and later on he
tried to cover his tracks but Stack
Overflow had this history at which email
addresses had been against the account
so I just one of these simple little
operational security OPSEC errors and
eventually brings him undone so that was
Ross he's now in jail for probably
forever if you don't sort of get out
when you run like a 40 million dollar
under on drug market and try and execute
people so he's staying there another guy
this one here jihadi John so jihadi John
was an interesting character he was in
Syria and he liked to chop people's
heads off which is probably what some of
these guys liked to do and the
interesting thing was they do these
videos and you know rah rah rah chopped
head etc and he had this stick British
accent which apparently is unusual for a
Syrian jihadi and and they're trying to
figure out who he is because he's got
the mask on and everything and you can't
really see so the authorities are
watching and they're obviously watching
a lot of stuff that's coming in and out
of Syria connection-wise and
they find that there's someone buying
web development software in the UK from
a Syrian IP address and in order to get
a bit of a discount they use the student
ID I know this guy mohamed emwazi so so
in order to save a few bucks from his
Syrian liras Shimon salir or something
like that he's bought this web design
software and how's that likes chopping
off people's heads CSS HTML anyway so
they found him identified him I was
reading the news just the other day he
apparently had a meeting with the drone
recently so he won't be doing any more
chopping of heads or web development
either as it may be that yeah yeah it's
just such a stupid little thing isn't it
anyway so we're happy with that it's
good that he got caught another really
interesting case of criminals getting
caught is this one now this is curious
for several reasons number one this is
the girlfriend of someone who was known
as women you can see the second line
there were Murr and Kevin crew and
wormer liked hacking Texas law
enforcement now I've not been to Texas
before but I always have the impression
as an Ozzie you know how we get these
impressions of the US I don't reckon
they have a lot of sense of humor over
there about people hacking them not in
Texas so anyway he's gone around hacking
the cops in Texas and at some point in
time he said to his girlfriend he's
girlfriend was in Melbourne too
he said hey I've got this really good
idea right what you do is you print out
this sign you lean over like this and
then with your iPhone you take a photo
and then we'll dump it on the web sites
after we own them now what does your
iPhone capture when you take photos XF
started air like a Chanel are like nine
decimal points or something like that so
inevitably what's then happen is the
cops have pulled the data they've gone
out look at this she's down in Melbourne
it's down in one turn and Melbourne and
then I can only assume that they've got
like a general location might be an
apartment building and they've had to
take the photo and somehow match it and
figure out who the individual is but
here's what I found
especially curious about this this is
who it was alright this is the girl this
is were man next to her and they look
normal right like they look like
perfectly normal people they don't even
have hoodies right and they're going
around hacking Texas law enforcement and
to me this speaks volumes that earlier
point about democratization of hacking
there are so many people that get
involved in breaking into things that
are otherwise very normal respectable
people and they just turn out to be like
this now this also got me thinking
because we've got this case here where
they're these normal everyday people
breaking into our things or we make it
too easy
is this something we're doing and I say
we as in us as developers are we
building software which is too
vulnerable so I went looking and I found
some stuff and this was one of the first
things I found just tell me when you
have a sense of what might be wrong here
that's good isn't that you never forget
your password if you have to reset your
password you have a problem you can't
share it with anyone which means you
also can't get any phone calls you can
google this text and you will find this
site it does exist it's real that's out
there which is kind of curious so
sometimes we are making it too easy give
you another good case this is Betfair
Betfair is an online betting site based
in the UK and i was watching a
discussion this was just last year a
discussion between a journalist and
Betfair support and the journalist is
saying to Betfair support he says i've
just gone on to the password reset on my
Betfair account which is what you see
here I entered my username which is my
email address and my date of birth and
then I set a new password didn't have to
get an email all we had to do was have
the email address and date of birth and
the Betfair person is arguing with them
he's going down and I like this isn't
right you know it doesn't work that way
and first of all if everybody any of you
have anything to do a social media
accounts representing companies don't
argue with your customers on Twitter
it's a public timeline and someone like
me will see it and then go and test it
for myself because he was right and this
argument kept going and I eventually
recorded a video of the whole thing just
cool is so ridiculous but what what
ended up happening is that looks like
the penny dropped and the Betfair guys
gone okay right yes that does work that
way that you shouldn't share your
username with anyone and the journalist
was going but it's my email address
that's how I get email I give it to
people and they send the email to me and
then then bit fairs going well shouldn't
be sharing your birthdate with people
and the Jenners like like presents and
cake and stuff like that and and he was
right the journalist was right and
Betfair had this really screwy
implementation now the funny thing is I
did this talk in Amsterdam last year in
a keynote for for a no Worcester
conference security conference and after
I did exactly I did just there this guy
came up to me after the talk and he
handed me a card
it was Betfair security so I shouldn't
I'm in size trouble but the guy was
really cool and what was really
interesting he said look we knew this
was bad like we knew this was ridiculous
but a marketing manager somewhere said
that we should do this and it was only
after we got bad press that their
handles forced and they actually fixed
the thing and that has happened to me
more than once the exact same scenario
someone's come up after I've used
someone as an example and said look we
knew this was bad but it required a
little bit of leverage publicly in order
to fix it so I feel a little bit too
sorry sometimes for the people behind
these accounts
Betfair now here's another one I found
this is JavaScript on a web form for the
login page just see if you can see the
problem your moment
now a lot of you laughing but I think
you're judging it too harshly think
about the upsides right scalability
doesn't matter how many people are
trying to log in at the same time
responsiveness no post backs right it's
just you enter it in bang look I'm
logged on wasn't that fast marketing
manager is very happy when he sees that
because it's immediate and people do
these things but think about it also
like okay the developer has to do
something stupid granted when testers
come along if they're not technical and
they test it it's like behaves as
required you know they don't actually
see the mechanics that are just behind
this very high-tech control called view
source uh-huh
so so sometimes we see things like that
which is a little bit scary here's
another one just recently this is a site
map this is the email address and
password of every single person on the
site in the site map this is a major US
is P of obfuscated their name but it was
legit that's what it was I checked it
the other day fortunately they've fixed
it but you can always kind of imagine at
some point someone has gone well like
users a sort of entities in the system
and a site map is kind of mental model
entities and then their passwords like
attributes of the entities so it might
been giving them too much benefited out
but there's what they did this happens
so we see some really scary stuff this
is obviously like I want to say miss
configuration but it's not even miss
configuration because someone at some
point had to code this and say let's put
all the stuff in the site map other
times we just see outright bad code so
this was one that popped up last year as
well and this is a bad case of sequel
injection and in case you haven't seen
sequel injection happened before my talk
first thing tomorrow we're going to do
this we're going to break some stuff
first hand but this one line of code
here where we concatenate in this sequel
statement with some data in a text field
he's vulnerable to sequel injection this
was from last year a blog post from last
year teaching other people how to write
a password reset feature other people
are going to this blog post and copying
the code and building their own
applications
this is why sequel injection is still
such a big problem a little bit further
up from here they needed to define the
connection string I want to show you how
they did the connection string and just
see if you can spot any problems with it
so other than the fact that this is
really not how you want to define a
connection string a nice bit on that
that ID kind of lets you do anything si
si can't you can do anything to the
database that password I hope everyone
knows what is wrong with that password
and the thing is some people would say
we'll look it's just a demo just an
example you know like this is not the
thing that you meant to be paying
attention to but any piece of code that
you put on the web will get copied and
pasted and people will build other
things from there so that's that's a bit
of a problem we're obviously making
things really easy on hackers when they
break into our systems but I think that
we're also making it too easy on the
users using our systems to do stupid
things
in fact sometimes we're encouraging it
give an example this is Lego and on the
Lego website you need to create a
password right if you on a create an
account and they give you a bit of
advice this is really really bad advice
now it's not just this short but that
like look at the language of it big and
small letters and I suspect that they're
trying to appeal more to kids I mean
it's it's Lego you can imagine local
kids using it but this is also not
really the advice we want to be giving
our kids it's not the precedent we want
to set right like we don't want to be
saying hey mate like go and create an
account and look at what Lego says don't
take security advice from Lego it's the
lesson here so that one is that one's
quite unusual and it sets consumers
end-users up for failure this one is
also problematic and this is problematic
for multiple reasons now first of all if
you've got a system which is banning
certain words like wankers and another
whole lot of other naughty words they're
not
word Lister's in JavaScript and it makes
her very entertaining reading why are
they blocking that and I'll give you a
hint they're not blocking password
abc123 they're only blocking naughty
words put another way do you think when
you create an account and you use a
naughty word in your password the
hashing algorithm gets a little bit
offended a little bit upset hashing
algorithm doesn't care
however the operator at the other end
who can see your password because it's
not being stored properly or they're
requesting it over the phone which is a
very insecure transport mechanism the
operator does get offended so when we
see naughty words like this it's because
a human is going to see it somewhere and
that tells you something about the way
they're storing passwords kind of ironic
to Branston of all people to be sort of
a little bit politically correct you
know let's not use words that might
offend you know this is a guy who every
time he launches something is just there
like a bevy of bikini babes and a tank
so here's an interesting character now
one of the other things we see when it
comes to security on the web obviously
we have a lot of a lot of rules around
things like passwords we also often
require things like security questions
you know they're going to ask you a
question and only you should know the
answer to the question and that's like
another layer of verification they can
ask you something else this is not how
you do security questions this is
problematic and it's problematic because
it's not a security question pub trivia
question right it's like what is the
capital which is ridiculous and this is
something which has such a well-known
answer that is ubiquitously known and if
you don't know it you've got Google then
it's crazy and then you go to the other
extreme and you get security questions
like this why
can you imagine the grandmother calling
the dog and that's it's just a security
questions . really problematic for so
many reasons and part of the reason is
we're so bad at creating them you know
and i don't say we as an industry when
we create questions if you're asking
what people's favorite color is that's
not too good because you can enumerate
that it's going to be the red green blue
or a small percentage of answers that
are something else
so when i see stuff like this and we see
this over and over again where you look
at a website and you go why did they do
that this is such a bad security
anti-pattern you start to wonder if
maybe the problem is us so maybe we're
being taught the wrong thing because
there's a lot of education out there
online targeted at developers that
example before thought sequel injection
in it targeted at developers here's how
to build a password reset feature so I
went looking and I thought I'll find
some more stuff online to do with how we
are teaching people about online
security and I found this little video
it's a slide on the giggles but like the
video at the start right it's a kid
they're having a guy you know give him
credit I can understand why they're
going to make some mistakes and you know
that's that's fine as a kid we can tell
there's a lot of other material online
though teaching developers about
security that's not made by kids a lot
of it's made by professional
organizations professional training
organizations and some of them produce
training like this now have a look at
this and just tell me when you spot the
problem here I'll know because everyone
will start laughing
what's the problem with base64
encryption by 64 decryption base64 is
encoding and encoding has decoding it is
not encryption yet this online training
resource is saying to people just base64
encrypt your credit card you're really
gonna upset PCI if you do that you're
probably not going to be able to take
payments anymore if they figure out
you're doing that professional online
training now it's really interesting as
well they have a look at the sorts of
questions people ask online about
security and particularly some of the
answers you get and I was browsing
around Stack Overflow a little while ago
and someone asked the question they said
I would like to build a system and store
passwords securely that's a good
question but there are some really
interesting answers and this was one of
them now let's have a look at this and
see what this is like in terms of
passwords storage and who knows what's
wrong with this one
let me walk you through it you take your
password such as H a I not a good
password yeah AJ hi and then for each
character in the string you get the
ASCII value and you add five and then
you store that and as per the
description at the bottom your output
now in contains the encrypted string
guess how you decrypt it but here's the
really hilarious thing I've got this
screen kept on one of my blog post there
was this there was another answer which
also used base64 encryption and then
there was a third answer and it
referenced this when I said no no no
this is not the best way to do what you
do is you get the street you get every
character you get the S key value of it
and you add 13 because it's stronger a
kid you not it's on my blog post I took
some backups of them just in case they
were deleted from Stack Overflow which
they were shortly afterwards and at
least Stack Overflow is a curated sort
of Q&A site so this sort of stuff drops
to the bottom but one of the things that
struck me is that this answer came very
very quickly after the question and I
don't think that someone just sat there
and typed it out where do you reckon
they got it from it's ah no I did that
last year
you know they've gone to their system
they've taken the code and they've
erected in the answer and the scary
thing for all of us to think about is
that we all have passwords in other
systems that are stored this way I
guarantee it and frankly they stored
worse than this because we've all got
passwords in a lot of systems that are
just plain text as bad as it sounds this
is better than plaintext if finally to
confuse people but it is better than
plaintext so so it's like Stack Overflow
really interesting you know looking at
the things people ask and the answers
you get here's another really
interesting question that tells you
something about the way some banks are
built
I can see CBA people here and I'm just
really hoping it well I think you guys
man imagine using that it's like every
other day something in WordPress is
broken and you can sort of only hope
that maybe this was just a bit of a
troll and it wasn't anything serious but
this is the thing right security is a
confusing concept for many people you
know there's all this stuff about
hashing encryption and I can understand
why sometimes it's difficult to even
know the difference between PGP and
wingdings it's like look at the
wingdings there are little buildings and
aeroplanes like it looks like encryption
right and the only way you can decrypt
it is you've got to select it all and
change the font to like Arial or
something like that and then you can
figure out what it actually is so it is
kind of scary seeing that stuff and in
fairness like okay we do build a lot of
bad stuff as developers and I mean
collectively as an industry but I think
we also see a lot of bad stuff from our
users as well and let's face it there
are some stupid users out there we've
all had to deal with them right this is
the nature of the industry I'll give a
few examples a little while ago Twitter
was hacked twitting this is the
headlines every day Twitter gets hacked
whatever it can actually happen here
whose account is this it's Burger Kings
it's Burger King's account but they've
been hacked so this was a few years ago
this was not Twitter being hacked this
was Burger King doing something stupid
and now they're promoting McDonald's but
it's verified so it must be legit right
that's not what verified means Tesla got
done last year so I'm thinking with
Tesla verified account but bad password
practices it sort of makes me wonder
though like okay clearly what's happened
here is someone has been able to log in
to Burger King's account and change
attributes how does this happen like how
did Burger King disclose their passwords
and we can look to precedence good
precedent is last year
tv5 monde in France got hacked their
twitter got hacked and this bloke from
the from the TV companies come online
he's doing an interview explaining air
we got hacked look we have no idea how
we got hacked you know as he sits in
front of all the passwords pinned up on
the wall behind him which wasn't a real
good look
and obviously the penny dropped and they
weren't okay all right this is probably
how it happened so they came on TV the
next day to explain how this thing
happened and there's this guy sitting
there post at night that's all good this
is why we have password managers folks
not post-it notes so this is a bit of a
problem we're obviously uses to do
stupid things and pretty much every
single time we see Twitter hacked it is
someone has done something stupid with
their password they've reused it it's
weak they've disclosed it some way maybe
fallen for a phishing attack but they
have made a mistake somewhere I think
though that very frequently we as an
industry make it really easy for users
to do stupid things in fact we
conditioned them to doing stupid things
and I'll give you a really good example
of that it's a QR barcode scanner that
needs a lot of access to a lot of things
if you want to scan a QR code with this
app you need to let them see your
calendar maybe they're scheduling it got
to give me a contact your location the
problem I have with this though is what
do you reckon the one thing is most
users see on this screen except all
right like it's the big button that is
getting between them and performing the
activity that they downloaded the theme
for in the first place so the users just
going to go great except we'll jump into
it most people probably don't know what
these security controls actually mean
and of course Google will say well you
know you've got to actually grant
permission yeah but you're not really
thinking about it you know so this is
more an issue with the manufacturers of
this app obviously so this is a problem
and we are conditioning users to stupid
security things by doing this we're even
conditioning them to stupid security
things when they go to buy an HDMI cable
did you ever know
that you need an HDMI cable with
antivirus protection because there's not
enough crap out there already about HDMI
right and not enough bud
but imagine right your average consumer
walks into the store and they've got to
buy an HDMI cable and they got to and
they're comparing them this one's good
antivirus this one doesn't what I'm
going to do and this is the problem
because we conditioned people to do
these ridiculous security things and I
don't think it's necessarily the
individuals themselves we have to blame
because we've got to look at a bit of
the way our messaging works as well so
the way that we're communicating to
individuals and particularly when you
look at the way social media accounts of
big companies online communicate you see
some really crazy stuff so I saw this
one a little while ago and what's
happening here is the guys said hang on
a second girl has said I'm entering my
credit card onto the page it's HTTP how
can I trust the page if it's HTTP which
is a perfectly reasonable position to
take and Twitter's said well don't worry
you may have missed the bitmap we have
on the page it explains it's secure
there's an interesting thing as well
with these these logos write us see
these verified by Verisign logos there's
the obviously norton ones there's a
whole bunch of different logos I saw a
talk last year and I learned something
really really interesting those logos
are not the developer just putting a
bitmap on the page they get a service
say in this case from from Norton where
they will scan the site on a regular
basis for vulnerabilities and that logo
is loaded dynamically from the service
during the scanning and whilst you're
passing everything you keep getting the
logo and this talk had the best name of
any talk of ever seen before it was
called clubbing seals the ecosystem of
security logos and what they wanted to
do was prove how stupid these seals were
so what they said is here's the trick
you wanna to a site with one of these
logos okay day by day by day logo still
their logo still they're like all logos
gone what does it mean right logos gone
it means now they have a security
vulnerability because it's removed on
but it gets better because then they go
okay well now we got to figure out why
the logo was removed we got to know and
what the vulnerability was so what you
do is you go and set up your own site
that's a reverse proxy to their site and
then you go to Verisign and you say I
would like to sign up for your service
and they scan your site which actually
scans their site and they tell you
exactly the vulnerabilities clever
clever you probably knew security seals
were useless anyway but this just goes
to show it so that's that's one example
here's another one there's a British
guess what there is this thing that
seems to be happening lately where
various websites block you from pasting
a password and it's not just that
they've got like an on paste event and
they stop you but they might look at key
presses and they might look at other
heuristics about how the password was
entered and the problem is is that if
you're really concerned about your
security and you use a password manager
with you or should be using and it
automatically inserts the password into
the field you have a problem it gets
blogged and as ridiculous as this may
seem it's not a one-off because just two
days ago I found this one how does a
brute-force attack against the ability
to paste a password work because the
only way I can figure it out is you've
got to have like an army of hackers all
pasting at the same time because how
else do you brute-force a paste feature
so so that's a couple of good examples
another really interesting thing that
you often see happen on social media is
conditioning people to send sensitive
information over Twitter this is a our
UK company and what ie was doing is
saying hey just DMS all your details now
if I was to create a Twitter account and
call it a esupport and then when someone
like Jay Shepard complained about a
problem I replied to them and said just
DM me your details how many people would
I get Twitter would shut me down sooner
or later but I would get a bunch of
accounts I bet you absolutely doesn't
they're verified in my account wouldn't
because I just put their logo on and
call it something that sounds like it's
legitimate 'support my favorite however
this one was from a few years ago but my
favorite and one that I still can't
quite figure out was from Tesco in the
UK they're like a big bullies over there
and here's what Tesco had to say when I
pointed out that they might have a few
problems I I can't even begin to fathom
like how that actually works so they had
dramas absolutely everywhere and I I
write up a few pieces and and they
didn't they didn't like some of it and
they but I mostly did it because of
answers like this like often I'll say
something and I'll tweet them and go hey
you might want to do this or that or
whatever and it's usually only after
they say something fundamentally stupid
and again I do appreciate that it's like
a social media person who knows nothing
about security but for God's sake if
someone engages with you like that a
really simple answer is sure wouldn't
you DM me the details why don't we take
it offline why don't we not have this
debate in the public sphere where it may
not end well so that was that was sort
of the advice that we're giving people
via social media and look I mean a lot
of that was kind of funny granted there
are other aspects of security that was
saying that that can be really really
serious and that this is sort of like
that the serious part of the talk but
it's I find it fascinating and it's
social medicine was anyone in the Ashley
Madison data bridge good answer correct
Dan's best answer is actually who no no
never heard of him before
so Ashley Madison was hacked in July
last year there their modus operandi was
pretty explicit you know this is not
like an adult website it's not a normal
relationship website this is let's have
an affair their whole promotional
campaigns everything was around life is
short have an affair so in July last
year someone broke in stole all their
data and said if you don't shut down
we're gonna dump it all publicly and
they gave a sample of just two records
and the two records were legit the
people in those records see here this is
my data I was on there so we got through
to August just a little bit later than
this time of the month last year and
everything got dumped publicly and it
was over 30 million unique accounts and
these are individuals who signed up to
the website with the express intent of
having an affair because that is what
the website says and everyone went nuts
which is understandable because this is
like a massive breach of privacy and
regardless of where you stand
ethically on the position of having an
affair to spread all of that all around
the web and make it so easily accessible
was just a really really negative thing
you know for everyone involved now when
something like this happens you get a
lot of people who want to capitalize on
the misfortune of other people so you
get things like this this is a site
which allowed you to search for people
in Ashley Madison now for context some
of you may know I run a site called have
I been poned where there are 1.3 billion
accounts from data breaches and you can
search and find whether you've been
impacted in Ashley Madison in some cases
Adobe 100-plus other data breaches but
when this happened it was really clear
that it's going to do damage to people
if others can find that you have an
account so I made sure that the only way
anyone could find out if you had an
account is if you can get an email sent
to the address you're searching for so
there is no disclosure risk incidentally
many sites of this ilk there was another
one called Adult Friend Finder
only a few months before that they got
hacked you can still go to their
password reset page and will tell you if
someone has an account
not so they disclose it anyway then
anyway I didn't want my site doing that
sites like this did want to do that and
because everyone was going nuts suddenly
realizing that first of all there was
this thing called Ashley Madison because
for most people it's something I didn't
know about but secondly gone
I wonder if Bob next door was in there
you know I wonder if my local MP lsn't I
wonder if I'm boss within that people
wanted to find out because they're nosy
bastards they just wanted to go and see
who they could find in this data so
sites like this popped up but why right
so what is the value proposition why
stand up a site like this it makes more
sense when you see it in context right
ads ads everywhere divorce lawyer ads
ads for spying software because they
know that if you're here you are a nosy
bastard and you want to spy on other
people some of the ads were from a
company called M spy who was hacked
several months earlier and had all their
data exposed so so now you've got M spy
who was hacked being promoted on the
Ashley Madison search page who was
hacked and the whole thing just goes a
bit inceptions like everyone's hacking
everyone's it was worse than this there
are other sites that stood up which then
tried to exacerbate the spread of these
searches so there's one called trust
afire P I group in Inouye and they
decided that not only should you be able
to search for people but after you
search for people you should be able to
tweet about it so they had social
integration which is like just click the
button and then click the Twitter button
and then window that pops up and you do
this and they thought it was such a good
idea that they even favorited it as well
that's the trust of a logo a little blue
one now I can understand Jackie in this
case going you know look we've had a
nasty breakup or something I wonder if
he was on there you know make it feel a
bit better if I could find him so I can
get her curiosity I struggled more with
this one friends like those Wow
you know they were encouraging you to go
and search for your friends and then
share the fact that you had found your
friend in order to get more people to do
the same thing and then what they did is
they
said if you want to contact us and give
us 500 bucks we'll tell you what data
has been leaked about you in Ashley
Madison so that's how they monetized
when this broke and I made the data
searchable via people who could verify
their identity and I wrote a bit about
it I just got bombarded by emails I got
hundreds if not thousands of emails from
people that were in the Ashley Madison
data breach that were now petrified as
being being outed because many of them
were having affairs many of them also
weren't they were women in there who
said I created an account there several
years ago because I was worried my
husband was cheating on me found he was
cheating on me
messy divorce moved on with my life I'm
now happily married with someone else
except my email address shows up on
there and it looks like I was a member
of Western medicine so really important
lesson there sites like this just
because there's an email address on
there doesn't mean that they were out
there having an affair but some people
were having an affair and other people
certainly had intense to have affairs
and as much as we may not like that idea
when you see some of the things they
said you realize how bad it was for
these people I've read this before going
to bed one night which wasn't a real
good idea but you know look I can't be
your guidance counselor you can't sort
of write to me go on committing suicide
and then there are multiple messages of
this nature so this had a really really
serious impact on people and sort of
that the last part of the serious bit is
it's just really interesting most the
time we build systems and their users
and they're sort of IP addresses and
user agents and very anonymous people to
us then at the other end we do have
people that have real lives and in some
cases lives that were destroyed people
killed themselves over the Ashley
Madison data breach people killed
themselves because there are security
flaws that ultimately disclose this info
and yes they were having an affair and
all that sort of stuff as well but
obviously as security that site had a
really major impact on a lot of people
now with that done there's some really
interesting stuff when we get to sort of
the IOT bits of the world and you've
probably all seen some funky IOT stuff
and we're going to talk specifically
about IOT in a moment but even just
basic things where we take something
that is digitized and we put it in the
context of the physical world and we end
up with unexpected security
vulnerabilities vulnerabilities like
this you can imagine that like they've
done their threat modeling and they're
worried about evil cyber actors
nation-states they didn't have an
envelope with a window in the threat
model simple as things like this bring
you undone another one that I think
hilarious and I've seen multiple
instances of this is this now in case
you're not familiar with what's going on
here
these are RSA tokens used for two-factor
authentication and what someone has done
here they're actually been very
ingenious they've said the problem with
two-factor is the second factor so what
we're going to do is we will stick the
tokens onto a box we'll put the pins
above them because you need a pin as
well they've been office coated here and
then we'll point a webcam at it and then
you just load the webcam probably
publicly accessible and you've got
everything you need
I must find it and use it in a talk one
day but I saw a tutorial that teaches
you how to do this with code samples and
everything and it's even OCR in the
number on the 2f a token the thing that
people will do so that's that's a good
sort of physical security problem
another problem we had when it relates
to security of physical devices and this
was this was just last year was this one
VTech you know see the VTech hack last
year so VTech was was really nasty
because involved kids and what actually
happens is this journalist he Lorenzo I
rise from motherboard he emailed me one
day and said look I've had a hacker give
me a whole bunch of data that is
allegedly from this Hong Kong toymaker
VTech and he asked if I could help him
verify it and I went through it and I
found about 4 million adults a physical
address email phone number all the usual
stuff that's in a data breach and in
total about 6 million children name
gender age photos
foreign key to the parents and a know
where they live and this guy's pulled
all the data out of the VTEC system now
that this good news story to the that
sort of came out in the wash with this
is that he only gave it to the
journalists and the journalists only
gave it to me and I deleted everything a
little while back so I don't have any of
it the guy got arrested in the UK and I
assume that motherboard deleted their
copy too so kind of it ended as well as
something like that could but one of the
first things that I did when Lorenzo
gave me the data is I went okay well
let's we got to figure out is this legit
and sort of the first step for me when I
get a data breach is I go to the website
of the organisation and I have a look
around and I go how likely is that these
guys from hack so no penetration testing
or probing or doing anything I shouldn't
do just use the website and have a look
at how it works and one of the things I
noticed is they had a little flash app
where you could log on to this service
so flash there's your first warning sign
log on it says and of course the flash
app is calling an API and when I logged
on the API returned this result why you
returning internal sequel statements in
your API there are many other things
which are actually far worse than this
but when you see stuff like that if you
see sequel statements anywhere on the
public side of a web application you
know something's going to be bad
so that was VTech and yet look this was
a disaster it was a real mess it showed
they've got absolutely no idea what
they're doing with security they have
actually now moved into home security
products this is not a Jake it's funny
but it's not a joke so they're selling
home security products which is which is
kind of alarming but while we're on the
subject at home the other thing of
course we're getting in the home is a
lot of IOT stuff
this is lifx ozzie invention so he
should be kind of proud that we've got
something on the world stage doing well
they had a vulnerability vulnerability
in the light globes and the interesting
thing is a lot of people say when we
have a vulnerability in something like
like loads they go well if a hacker
manages to like put the bedroom in a
disco mode
the key their vulnerability disclose the
Wi-Fi password of the network and what
they said is okay now getting on patchy
light bulbs how do you do that it's one
thing but we don't think anyone got
owned by their light bulbs which is kind
of weird too because if you did get
owned by your light bulbs it's because
someone else is connected to your
network and you're not going to think to
blame the light bulbs I pulled another
example of this down just last night
these are vulnerabilities in Ostrom
connected light bulbs so lots of stuff
like clear WPA PSK is pressured keys
things like XSS the light bulbs have an
XSS vulnerability this is something
that's really hard to grasp but there's
one more thing that's even harder to
grasp when it comes to connected things
is this anyone got one of these they're
from Japan as all funny toilet things
are if you've ever been to Japan you
know what I mean it's like you go in
there and it's like is this the ejection
button what is it because there's just
buttons and stuff everywhere anyway so I
found this stuff on the web and there's
these three screens and I think the
first one the one on the top left is
some sort of a splash screen geez
so that bad the one in the middle though
I'm particularly curious about it's a
calendar somehow generated by the toilet
somehow containing some form of
event-driven data as best I can tell and
then you've got the one on the front and
I kid you not this is not something that
I've fabricated but it's obviously a
music player and the toilet is playing I
can't get no satisfaction you can google
this and you will find it so I showed
this a couple of years ago one of my
talks and I said the problem that we're
going to have now is that we will have
vulnerabilities in the toilet and we
will have all sorts of problems we never
thought we would ever have and then it
happened Trustwave had to put out an
advisory and this is terrifying
and then I showed this at a recent talk
and someone said yes this is known as a
backdoor attack all right and on that
note that is the scary state of security
thanks very much everyone if anyone does
want to ask questions we've only got
lunch now so what I have to rush
anywhere so if you want to ask as a
group will come up and please do